quand vous voyez là la folie criminelle
le mépris de toute vie humaine de
vladimir poutine pur produit du système
stalinien vous ne pensez pas qu'il
incarne une forme de continuité avec le
soviétisme
[Musique]
non vous rigolez ou quoi non non mais
c'est un libéral c'est un mec de droite
pourquoi vous dites pas que c'est un
dirigeant de droite libérale qui a vendu
tout ce qui était justement publique
d'état il a cassé justement une économie
qui était certes diriger mais lui il a
tout privatiser c'est lui qui a créé des
oligarques qui aujourd'hui achète des
villas et des yachts que l'on voit sur
la côte d'azur c'est un gars de droite
qui flirte avec l'extrême droite et qui
a réagi de l'union soviétique mais mais
il a la nostalgie des z'arts
c'est ça sa référence c'est l'histoire
de ce peuple aussi mais rien s'est il a
construit un système aujourd'hui ultra
libérale nationaliste il se comporte
comme un dictateur il a appauvri le
peuple russe et d'ailleurs cette guerre
lui permet de masquer
les terribles effets de son 2e en
direction du peuple russe et la pauvreté
qui grandi là bas elle n'allait pas lui
mais il est plus proche de la droite et
de l'extrême droite que des valeurs
défendues par le parti communiste
français mais il a plusieurs fois dit
son admiration pour mais c'était par
exemple mais babin donc regarder auprès
de qui fait référence à notre
dictateur qui a du sang sur les mains
lui et
et donc est que nous ne supportons pas
donc
justement il y là il n'a rien à voir
avec nous c'est quand même c'est quand
même gonflé allez plutôt demander à ceux
qui se mettent en photos sur des tracts
avec lui
c'est plutôt ça sait référence vous me
verrez jamais mettre des photos
de poutine dans mes tracts en saluant
son engagement ça c'est pas le genre de
la maison
[Musique]